-My first guest tonight is one
of the biggest names in music.
She is a Grammy winner
who's had four number-one songs
on the Billboard Hot 100.
Her latest single, "Up,"
has already gone up
to number one
on Apple Music and iTunes.
Here is the one and only
Cardi B!
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
-It is so good to see you.
You look fantastic.
-Thank you.
-The last time
I think we were here together,
we co-hosted the show.
And you had baby -- you were
still pregnant with baby,
and now you have a little
1 1/2-year-old running around.
-Thank you.
I can't wait --
Are we gonna host --
When the world
is back open again,
I want to host your show
again with you.
That was so fun.
-You were fantastic,
and, honestly,
it's an open invitation.
Come back whenever you want to,
please.
I got to meet that baby.
-For sure.
-You've had a very busy
past few months.
In August,
you released the song "WAP,"
and it became one of
the biggest songs of the year.
And it had one of our pals
on there, Megan Thee Stallion.
How did the song come together,
and was --
was the plan always
to have her on it?
-Well, I wanted a couple
of girls in the song.
You know when you have ideas,
like, "I want to have this
and that girl in the song,"
I really wanted to have Megan,
but I didn't know her that well.
And our stylists linked us up,
and when our stylists
linked us up,
we kicked it off really well.
And I said, "Oh, girl, I got --
We'll just say,
I got a song for you."
"Well, I got a song for you."
And she loved my song,
and she hopped on it,
and we made "herstory."
♪ Herstory ♪
-You've made "herstory."
Oh, my gosh.
You did, you crushed it.
She is super-duper fun,
by the way.
-She is.
-Your new song, "Up,"
came out last week.
Congrats on this.
Already number one.
After "WAP," did you go like --
Do you get pressure
to put out another song?
Do you go like,
"I don't want to do it.
I already scored"?
-Yeah, I do feel pressure,
but then I feel, like,
pressure from my fans,
like, "All right.
We want another --
We want another song."
-Ready.
-So the pressure
was even more big
because I haven't released
a solo single in like two years.
So I was like, "Oh, my God,
I just want to go top 10."
And it's predicted
to go probably number 2
on the Billboard Hot 100.
So I'm like, "Oh, wow.
I exceeded my limit."
I'm extremely happy.
-Oh, fantastic.
I love it.
It's, like, up.
And then, "If it's up,
then it's stuck"...
-Yeah.
-...I'd never heard before,
but that's -- Did Offset --
Is that who --
I heard that he had something
to do with that phrase?
-Well, he says that a lot.
I don't know if
it's a down South thing.
Because after the song came out,
I thought it was, like,
a Georgia thing,
but then people would say,
"Ah, no, we say that
in New Orleans.
We say that in Florida."
I'm like, "Okay, man, listen.
All right, I guess, whatever."
-"You got it. It's yours,
it's yours, whatever."
-"It's yours."
[ Both laugh ]
-But if it's --
if it's up, then it's stuck.
-Yeah.
-What does that mean?
-Um...
So, have you ever
taken a poop, right?
-Hmm.
-And it don't come out?
-Mm-hmm.
-It's just up, and it's stuck.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
All right.
I mean, I guess you could
take from it whatever you want,
you know?
There's other...you know,
ways to look at it, I guess.
-Yeah.
I was saying, if it's up,
that it's up here forever.
Once you get up...
[ Whistles ]
-It got -- It's a metaphor --
a metaphorical quote.
-Right? Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
You're floating, you're up,
and you're stuck up,
and good for you, because
you worked hard to get up,
and it's stuck,
and now there you go.
-Yeah, stuck.
-[ Laughs ]
-There's two -- There's
different ways to look at it.
"Up" is already awesome.
Is there a new album on the way?
Can we say anything or no?
-Um, I really want
my next project
or anything that's related
to music to just be my album.
I just got to focus
on a couple of more songs
and do music videos,
and, you know, do the whole
whoop-de-hoo,
so it's like, "Aw, man."
We just gotta make sure.
-Is it tough, with
the pandemic and everything,
to do, even to record a song,
let alone do a video for it?
-Videos, yes, of course.
Because there's certain things
that you can't do.
Like, you can't --
All right, so I did
this pyramid, right?
I did this pyramid
with some girls.
And the pyramid, we have to do
it less than 10 seconds
because it was more
than six people.
And due to COVID,
people can't be touching.
Even though you get tested
before the music video --
three times -- you get tested
the beginning of the week,
the day before, and the day of.
So that's extra, the money...
-Yeah.
-...spending in production.
-Oh, exactly.
But didn't --
also, didn't you just --
didn't you, like,
lick each other at some point
in the video?
-Yeah, like --
Yeah, we had to, like, beg.
-So, the pyramid --
the pyramid, they go,
"No, you cannot do the pyramid."
-Yeah.
-"But you can
French kiss each other."
-Because there was six --
Wait. It was five of us
in the shell.
But there was, like,
how many girls?
Like 10 girls together.
It cannot be more than
10 people in a room.
Like, it's just --
the craziest protocols.
The craziest.
-It's like, "No pyramid!
Stop it!
Whoa. Licking?
Oh, three of you
can lick each other.
Two --"
[ Both laugh ]
"Only two people in a pyramid.
Hey! Don't even --
Yes, you can lick. Of course
you can lick each other."
It's like, "What is going on?"
[ Both laugh ]
We don't know the rules.
-I'm telling you,
it's the craziest thing.
If you work in production,
you understand.
It is the craziest thing ever.
-The new "Fast and Furious."
Everyone's talking about this
'cause it's supposed
to come out in May.
We don't know.
But "Fast and Furious,"
it's "F9."
You're in the movie.
-Yeah.
-Well, this is major.
Wait, but --
-It is major.
-I have questions for you.
Cardi, you don't drive.
Is that right?
-No.
-So this is really acting.
[ Both laugh ]
'Cause I know you have cars,
but you don't -- ha ha!
But you don't --
Why don't you know how to drive?
Why don't you want to know?
Don't you want your license?
You have to.
-I do want my license,
because sometimes at nighttime,
like at 3:00 in the morning,
I want some ice cream.
-Yeah.
-And my husband
is just laying, sleeping.
I'm like, "Oh, gosh.
I'm just
gonna go to bed hungry."
-I checked out a couple
of episodes of "Cardi Tries"
on Facebook.
I love the idea of this.
It's basically
you try a bunch of things.
-Yeah.
-Is there anything
that you would not try?
-I will not try garbage pickup,
like garbage man
and stuff like that.
Because from the garbage,
a lot of rats
and frickin' raccoons
be coming out the garbage,
and I don't deal with that,
especially because
I'm a New Yorker.
So, no, no, no.
I will not do that.
-How about, uh --
How about, like, bungee jumping
or jumping out of a plane,
all that stuff?
-Oh, no, no,
I can't do that neither
because I am
very afraid of heights.
I do not like --
I don't like excitement.
-I think your life
is exciting enough.
You don't need more excitement.
-No, I'm not an exciting person.
I do not like being on Jet Skis,
none of that.
Like, your girl can't swim.
I can't swim.
You know, I can't drive,
I don't know what to do.
I just know how to rap, okay?
I just know how to rap and eat.
So...
-Well --
-That's what I want to do.
-It's really fun.
All the episodes
of "Cardi Tries"
are on Facebook Watch.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Cardi B trying out
life on a ranch
in the latest episode
of "Cardi Tries."
Take a look at this.
-[ Laughs ]
He's like, "More for me."
-Do you think
you're gonna want some pigs?
-Knowing that I gotta feed them
slops, I don't think I can.
They're so stinky
and oppressive.
They will run over my daughter.
-Right?
-We don't want pigs, sorry.
We don't want pig-ass men,
and we don't want
pigs as animals.
-No, we do not.
[ Both laugh ]
-I'm funny.
-More with Cardi B
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody!